[Music]
[Applause]
dear jack on behalf of the admissions
committee is my pleasure to offer you
admission to the MIT class of 2010 this
was a letter received by a good friend
of mine who was at the time a high
school senior in Arizona it was an
incredible moment MIT was the school
that jacket dreamt of going to since
sophomore year he worked hard and had
paid off who remembers that feeling of
euphoria when you get something for
which you've long might be in your first
job or getting into university
but this notice was soon gone Jack's
parents returned home to find the letter
scrunched up and tossed onto the floor
in his place lay a second letter with
that same MIT branding set with a words
financial aid office written below dear
jack it began as before but over the
neatly typed writing below with a red
scroll you're not rich enough to go here
Jack had written this but he was right
what's worse is it happened again Jack
got into USC he literally had the letter
of acceptance in his hand but again they
left him with a $55,000 gap which he
couldn't cover intimidated by the
prospect of significant student debt he
eventually accepted a place a lower
ranked University where he qualified for
in-state fees now I chose this story
because it's a very standard one Jack
was from a middle-class family both his
parents had paying jobs and that's
exactly the point this isn't just a
problem that affects some families this
is a problem that affects the majority
indeed four out of ten students who get
accepted to their first choice
universities declined because they can't
afford to go there 4 out of 10 we all
know how expensive tuition is but for
context for Jack's parents whose two
kids want to go to private four-year
universities it would account for 40% of
their combined salaries every year post
PACs and it's only getting more
expensive over the last 20 years tuition
costs have increased a hundred percent
above inflation in that same time we
didn't found the income four percent
it's increased a hundred versus four so
is it any wonder that student debt is
now 1.3 trillion dollars more than
Russia's economy is it any wonder that
43 million Americans hold student loans
43 million and nearly 10 million of them
are in default and is it any wonder that
student loan payments have now surpassed
groceries as the biggest monthly
expenditure for many households
it's no wonder to me even though I come
from a comfortable family I'm part of
these statistics I took out the maximum
government loans or Amanda grad and I
now back in debt at Stanford is there
nothing we can do nothing we can do to
stop Jack scrunching up his admissions
letter
well actually 41 billion dollars is
donated every year by alumni to colleges
that's enough to cover the tuition of
4.5 million Jack's and these donations
are growing so where's the money going
it's not going to Jack stop going to
people that need it most it's going to
Stanford going to Harvard it's going to
Yale
all of which already have significant
endowment it just me result like giving
welfare support to billionaires and the
problem is these donations are having
less and less impact let me take an
example last year 92 University spent
one point seven billion dollars on
recreation park projects it's got so bad
the New York Times did an article solely
on aquatic features at universities a
couple of examples from that article one
Louisiana State University has just
finished building a lazy river that
spells out LSU the school director of
recreation yes they have a director of
recreation at a school when you ask the
public relations for approval sure they
said then yes but well thank y'all for
the but but only if it's in our
signature very task go font they also
spent three million dollars on a habitat
for their mascot Tiger Mike Clemson's
38-acre
lakefront property includes blobs yeah I
didn't know what blobs were either so I
asked they're like floating mattresses
so that and I quote the director
recreation so that students can jump
around like on American ninja now these
are just two examples from the article
but we really don't need to look far
from home the rumors are that Stanford
spends $40,000 on every palm tree so
next time you go down palm drive think
of every single palm tree as a student
that could not afford to go to this
institution
this is at best a real misuse of
donations and it worse
it's a recreation park arms race that's
driving up the cost of tuition now don't
get me wrong a beautiful setting can
create a wonderful learning environment
but it's no use of students can't afford
to go there I'm not saying don't donate
to colleges Stanford claims the Manistee
of all Mays and funded important
projects but I urge you to consider
donating equally to institutions and
individuals and you could do that by
creating scholarships they had the
highest marginal impact and it's the
most efficient way to support students
your money goes straight to their
tuition and that's why I spent the last
year building going Mary comm we make it
easy for any donor to create a
scholarship of any size and give that to
the perfect student who shares their
interests values or background anyone
can create a scholarship in less than
three minutes time you can change the
life of the student like Jack in less
time than it takes you to order an uber
President Obama once said that the u.s.
is not a country that guarantees equal
outcomes but we do strive to provide
everyone with an equal shot his
predecessors described this as at the
core of the American dream at the moment
frankly there isn't an equal shot but if
the donors in education stop funding
ninja blobs and start donating directly
to students then there can be and the
next time a student like Jack receives
an admission letter he can accept it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]